champs d'oliviers partout partout
c'est marrant la lionne avec
on n'a pas une culture
ouais
le retour de nos francs
ouais c'est pas terrible
pour retourner à ok qu'est ce qu'on va
tourner en rond sans doute me re pas
leur à droite pour la cessoie qui reste
comme ça mais nous entoure je sais pas
ce qu'on va aller ravi tu vois des trucs
non c'est pas très intéressant
r
d'après la faille
on attend encore sous le choc
voilà c'est pas tirer dessus à gauche
que ses plus beaux et racé comme tu le
vois pas ce que twilight à l'heure aussi
où il aimait pas notre ami es vachement
bon maintenant voilà
ses propres intérêts verticale en fin de
compte
ce que l'on s'accroche dedans
là t'as pas flatteur on tape ovidiu de
tuer la vois la joie les soli solet et
il sert à petit en sert de dents chez
saint gobain entame seulement voilà ça
c'est la chaussée se dire en photo c'est
sublime
j'ai un peu pitié d'hélicoptères v
toi t'as pas fait attendre
ça c'était trop serré si transférer des
parties serrées souviens je cours à la
fois petit peloton d'image mois de
tournage ou peu de temps reculés
tu sois un peu pantois serré à mon avis
bon écoute ça marche ou pas chez vous
posions après 10,1 sur l'écran ça marche
comment que le people c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal il est graphiquement c'est
pas mal le début l'alimentaire
maintenant c'est pas intéressant un coup
sûr par derrière
on va revenir dessus
le retour dessus
c'est vraiment déçu a fait pas pâle
grappelli p
il n'y a pas de quoi non plus mais je
sais pas ce que tu as tué ses liens
passés du graphisme agricoles ce qui
pourrait expliquer je ferai certainement
des choses sa maman la beauté des dix
matches voilà faut que je trouve un joli
lieu en large les yeux pétillent soir à
la grande surprise des milieux voilà
effet ce relief sur 17 % sans peur aux
lièvres
alors c'est bien comme ça voilà voilà
voilà voilà dire à un peu vers l'arrière
de l'oeil du coc pas plus à l'est le
petit va tourner
elle revient un peu en arrière de plus
de 60 ans les genres et la bordure en
hiver maintenant on va perdre ou tard il
continue à voir un truc en bosnie plan
différent
cela revient à peu va faire grand chose